we go to the movies for a lot of reasons
but most of them can be boiled down to
our desire to feel or experience
something that we wouldn't be able to
otherwise that best filmmakers can put
us directly in touch with these emotions
on sensations and it can be pretty great
it can also be pretty seriously
distressing when skilled filmmakers use
their gifts to punch us straight in the
gut
particularly when that punch is
unexpected these are films are promised
us a rollicking good time and they
delivered but along with the thrills and
chills came moments of pure
unadulterated drama that lingered a long
after the credits rolled Star Wars The
Force awakens Star Wars Episode 7 the
force awakens was generally seen as a
satisfying return to form for the series
after the plotting lows of the prequels
for the story it told was occasionally
criticized as being not much more than a
rehash of the 1977 original it also gave
us memorable new characters like the
malevolent kylo Ren force-sensitive
scavenger ray and renegade stormtrooper
Finn plus the word welcome returns of
Han Solo and now general Leia Harrison
Ford's older and wiser harm was a
highlight and the revelation that kylo
Ren had been born Ben solo to Han and
Leia raised the film's dramatic stakes
considerably the scene in which Han goes
to confront his son on a bridge spanning
a seemingly bottomless abyss is fraught
with tension and for a moment Han
appears to be getting through to his son
until when to see and think of all it's
been speculated by fans ahan may have
gone to his death willingly in order to
help his son transition fully to the
dark side so he can successfully
infiltrate and bring down the first
order but even if this turns out to be
the case it doesn't make this scene any
less shocking abrupt or upsetting and
there wasn't even the first
heart-wrenching death in Star Wars Star
Wars a new hope when Star Wars was
released to theaters in 1977 nobody had
even seen anything even remotely like it
when you all know about the cultural
juggernaut it became but it's impossible
to overstate what a blaster filmmaking
and Genuity represented at the time the
project was almost shelved pre released
due to its budget and perceived a lack
of marketability also surprising was
just how many younger moviegoers were
traumatized during the film's most
heart-rending moments Darth Vader's
vanquishing of obi-wan Kenobi
wind earth you strike me down I shall
become more powerful than you can
possibly imagine
audiences were left with their jaws on
the floor when the Jedi Master lowered
his defenses as Luke Skywalker looked on
Luke's reaction mirrored the audience's
and even the rebels eventual triumph
during the film's conclusion wasn't
entirely enough to wipe away the sting
of Kenobi seemingly senseless death
Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom
Raiders of the Lost Ark became an
instant classic upon his 1981 release
and there was never any doubt that
audiences would get much much more of
The Adventures of Indiana Jones the
climax of that film was pretty
traumatizing in its own right what with
the angry spirits and Nazi face-melting
but 1984 Indiana Jones and the Temple of
Doom promised to go quite a bit darker
it was the film that created the pg-13
rating largely due to one unexpected
jaw-droppingly violent scene it comes
fairly early in the film as Jones and
sidekicks Willie Scott and shortround
observe a sacrificial ritual being
performed by the villainous mola Ram and
a snuggie cult
the scene traumatized young fans and
received strong criticism the New York
Times called the film to violence based
partly on that scene and probably the
one where they ate the monkey brains eat
see the extra-terrestrial Steven
Spielberg has never been unwilling to
toy with the feelings of his audience
even when giving his characters the
happiest of endings he's skilled at
drawing genuine performances out of his
actors his 1982 masterpiece ET the
extra-terrestrial is a bit of an
emotional roller coaster its climactic
scene in which young Elliott and his
friends evade federal agents in order to
help et get home manages to be
suspenseful action filled and hilarious
at once but it's not until the threat is
over and et is about to return safely
home of the waterworks start
[Music]
it's not so much to delivery of the
animatronic alien as it is he absolutely
heart crushing reaction shots of Henry
Thomas drew barrymore and Dee Wallace
literally falling to Annie's with
emotion even bullying big brother
Michael appears to be holding back the
tears and for many young viewers this
scene would have represented their first
exposure to genuine heartbreak and loss
its Stephen King's novel it is a
catalogue of pure unadulterated terror
and widely considered one of his finest
works the book had already received an
acceptable live-action adaptation in the
form of the 1990 TV mini-series so the
2017 allocation was viewed with a
healthy amount of skepticism
fortunately the cast and crew delivered
not only a ferocious new vision but one
of the very best horror films of the
last decade thanks in no small part to
Bill skarsgård absolutely masterful
portrayal of penny wise even viewers
already familiar with the novel or
miniseries couldn't help being shocked
to their cause by the characters
introduction young Georgie loses his
paper boat in a storm drain only to see
the clowns predatory eyes peering at him
from out of the drains darkness over the
course of their conversation the clown
convinces the boy to reach on in and
grab his boats it's the last decision
Georgie will ever make and the graphic
nature of his demise makes a scene land
with a punch that no television
adaptation could ever match
Avengers infinity war Marvel fans were
thrilled when the studio reached a deal
allowing for joint custody of Marvel's
flagship character Peter Parker the
amazing spider-man they were even more
excited when the MCU incarnation of
Spidey lived up to any expectation they
possibly could have had Tom Hollands
endlessly wisecracking version of the
wall-crawler
hit the sweet spot with fans that have
been left somewhat cold by Sam Raimi
spider-man trilogy
and Marc Webb's reboots news of
Holland's sixth picture contract meant
that we would be treated to Spidey's
adventures in the MCU for years to come
then we were given Avengers infinity war
the lead-up to the end of the MC use
first rephase Thanos mega rock we all
knew there would be blood
Thanos his killing of loki and Heimdall
in the pictures first five minutes
confirmed that the mad Titan was a
threat unlike any the Avengers at yet
faced but few expected the carnage of
the film's climax in which Thanos
actually manages to succeed in wiping
out half of all life in the universe
with one snap of his fingers watching
fan favorites like Doctor Strange and
Black Panther crumble to dust was bad
enough but Spidey's demise was utterly
crushing
of course he'll be back but in that
moment it didn't matter serenity the Fox
TV series Firefly aired for only one
season in 2002 but all these years later
its imprint on pop culture refuses to
fade a story of an intergalactic band of
near duels on the run from the Galactic
Alliance introduced us to the crew of
the Firefly class spaceship serenity
this included sardonic captain Malcolm
now Reynolds the second-in-command
Azzurri Washburn and a husband Hoban
wash Washburn a ship's wisecracking
pilots after the series have dropped
cancellation and creator Joss Whedon
gave fans a proper send-off with the
2005 theatrical release serenity but he
also saw fit to give them a healthy dose
of heartbreak wally was our heir late in
the film the crew succeeds in provoking
the Alliance into a battle for the
animalistic Reavers and wash manages to
pilot the damaged serenity through the
melee landing on the surface of the
planet over which the battle is taking
place just at the moment all appear safe
washer says his final words before being
impaled by a Reva spear dying instantly
in front of his horrified wife and
captain and a leaf on the wind Whedon is
well known for bestowing cruel fates
upon beloved characters but the death of
wash is one that even his most ardent
fans of a hard time forgiving him for
[Music]